the browns on friday afternoon and as we
speak
practicing 4 30 p.m eastern they got
back on the practice field for the first
time
all week because of their covet 19
non-outbreak
outbreak that eventually became an
outbreak they were calling it community
spread
even when it seemed obvious that there
aren't that
many infections in the community to
cause that many infections in the
building
there was spread but apparently they're
at a point now where they believe
there isn't an actual outbreak
among the browns or they wouldn't be
able to practice they continue to
monitor daily
the reports from the
the samples that are given the pcr tests
that go off-site and if this will go
right up until sunday
and we'll wait for the all clear on
sunday and it's the last game of the day
and hopefully the browns and the
steelers will be able to play i
think that no matter what they're
getting this game in
no matter what now is there a risk of
transmission to the steelers if they're
in that doughnut hole with incubation
period or the lag between
sample collection and test result yes
but they firmly believe that in an
open-air setting especially you're not
going to have transmission
to other people during a football game
specifically to your opponents
so i'd be stunned if this game doesn't
go forward in large part because
i don't know what your plan b is and i
don't think they want to find out
they certainly don't mike and it
certainly puts the browns at a
disadvantage but i
thought back to that raven steelers game
on thanksgiving week
remember when they let the ravens go out
there and have the walk through
and all of a sudden they really and
truly had an outbreak because it went
within the organization at that point so
i hope this isn't the case with the
browns i hope they're
certain that they've got this thing
under control because if they don't
we could see a huge outbreak over the
next few days
and and they have have thrown up the
caution flag anyway with dr alan sills
the chief medical officer
saying yesterday that they're now seeing
that spread within the facility so
hopefully they know and they're certain
that they've got this thing under
control mike
or the browns truly are going to be at a
disadvantage because they're going to
have a
lot more guys that can't play than they
currently do and besides all those
coveted guys
they listed seven players on their
injury report as questionable so they've
got a huge problem here in trying to go
beat pittsburgh
it was already a big problem for them to
try to beat pittsburgh i mean they
haven't done it in so long it's been
forever
forever they've lost 17 consecutive at
pittsburgh
but now mike with all these players out
it's going to be an even bigger task for
this team to try to beat pittsburgh
and i haven't seen whether today's
practice is a real practice or a
socially distanced walk through that's
what the ravens ultimately did right
before they got to play the steelers
but it was the practices on monday and
tuesday of thanksgiving week when the
nfl
still was holding out hope of playing
the game thanksgiving night that
fueled the spread and that's the thing
is there
a conscious risk that's being taken here
if it's not a socially distanced
practice
that is meaningless if you're trying to
get ready to play football if it's a
real practice
is there an enhanced possibility of
spread within
the browns that results in the
possibility of
game day spread in the locker room at
heinz field the visitors locker room
on the sideline on the field and does it
jump over to the steelers now
if as we assume the browns are going to
lose and i think the chances of them
winning get
get slimmer and slimmer all the time
with these guys not available and no
head coach on the sidelines
if they have more infections into next
week it doesn't matter they're done
it's over and i think there's that sense
of just getting to the finish line
especially for the browns if they do
lose
they'll be done it'll be over and the
nfl
can move on to the teams that will be
left the eight teams that will be left
after this weekend of football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports